hey hey Vsauce Michael here with some
things you can do online now guys let's
start the dongs off in the right hands
with mr. nice hands calm you can pull
his finger wordle.net analyzes text like
on a website and generates a free word
cloud with font sizes correlating to the
frequency with which the words are used
pretty awesome right but is it the most
awesomest thing ever calm the site pits
two things against each other and lets
you vote on which of the two things is
awesome for instance pilgrims vs. Andrew
Jackson I'm gonna have to go with the
pilgrims but periodic table or orson
welles which is awesome err okay it's
tough but i'm gonna have to go with
Mendeleev now the site tabulates
everyone's answers and runs a list of
what people currently consider to be the
most awesome notice that right now life
is being beat by the internet got a song
stuck in your head go to unhear it calm
a site dedicated to playing equally
catchy songs with the hope of removing
the one that's stuck in your head and if
you like what you hear check out toon
glue type in a band to add them to the
field and then expand them to see other
bands related now I also like music map
where you can enter a musician's name
and other bands orbit them at distances
related to how similar their styles are
if you're tired of music recognition
programs that don't allow you to sing
your own song or hum enter McDo me calm
it's still not perfect but I am terrible
and madami still understood what I was
trying to do I'm a loser baby so why
don't you kill me amazing another
flawless performance by Michael Stevens
Thunder shark 78 introduced me to frak
you
a series of mazes you continually shrink
down into the perspective is pretty cool
now let's get mathematical with Conway's
Game of Life this one's a doozy but it's
really famous right now I'm playing it
as a downloadable version for PC
Mac or Linux known as gali so the game
itself is simply a grid that I can fill
in and whether a cell is alive or dead
determines what the next generation will
look like what made this game so famous
is that using just a few deterministic
rules were able to create some quite
complex things now classically the rules
are very simple
the fate of a cell depends on the status
of its one two three four five six seven
eight neighbors if two or three cells
surrounded it's gonna be fine it's going
to continue to live but if fewer than
two or if more than three exist around
it it will die of isolation or
overcrowding now likewise if a dead
empty cell has three exactly three
neighbors it will come to life so the
next generation of this shape looks like
this it's amazing how just a few simple
deterministic rules can allow you to
create shapes like this one known as a
glider which across successive
generations actually locomote oh and GM
/ showed me a version where the cells
are mushrooms and the longer a cell
lives the bigger the mushroom gets but
what's a game of life without love the
media buffs sent me pretentious game a
wonderful interactive poem that's
touching but aware of itself and Connor
showed me an even more tragic love a
game where you play a guy in love with a
zombie get her to follow you but keep
her in a cage also cute is night of the
loving dead you play a skeleton who must
find his body parts to reunite with his
true love as you acquire organs like
your brain you can begin to use new
powers now if you're not in love with a
zombie and would prefer to prepare for
their attack the arsenite offers you map
of the dead a global Google map
delineating areas where zombie activity
will likely be highest in the event of
an outbreak it includes helpful
landmarks like nearby food and
ammunition shops so you can plan your
strategy now if this is all a bit too
scary for you relax with next boys Zor
de a collection of quick looping images
and silly music
gentoku discovered this neat interactive
scale of the universe tool we've covered
things like this before but you can
never have enough while we're out in
space let's get bigger playing cosmic
crush like almond phobias collide with
smaller items to grow larger and avoid
giant dangerous celestial objects here
on YouTube Vic cellent uploaded a really
well made interactive game you play
within a single video and his use of
annotations is quite ingenious and the
real majani made this impressive
interactive Domino video the tricks in
layout a really neat and you get to
choose a direction at the end of the
video let's hope it's the right one back
to metronomy subscribe to Vsauce for
more
[Music]